this video is sponsored by manscaped
which means you will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
hello everyone welcome to another q a
this is a personal q a but you can leave
gaming questions or personal questions
below i split them up into two different
videos two q and as a month first
question for this one
the first one is from lee hewer and it
says hey alana just wondering if you
have any response to the sony fanboys
who are harassing you on twitter
personally i think it's disgusting and i
wish you would go and work at an xbox
studio
um okay so i
it's like once a week there are like
masses of people i don't know
harassing me on twitter or like some man
i've never heard of makes a youtube
video and his comment is come get mad at
me here's the truth
i don't
care at all
not even a little bit i usually don't
even know that this stuff is happening i
won't have even seen it until people
come to me and are like i'm so sorry to
hear you're being harassed from my
perspective i'm not i had no idea what's
happening i don't care um i found out
that i was being
harassed
uh for playing tunic and putting xbox
game pass in the title and thumbnail
which i do
solely um well actually i do it on every
single video every video i put whatever
platform i played it on and what i'm
playing it on i do that for all of my
let's plays or almost all of them
sometimes i don't know if it's pc um so
i do it for xbox game pass because it
tends to make the videos get more views
because people realize that they have
xbox game pass and can play it that's it
um so i guess like playstation fans were
mad about it i don't know because i
didn't look at any of it uh i only
knew again because people like came to
the comment section of that video or
dm'd me and were like i'm sorry this is
happening and again it happens all the
time as far as i'm aware there were like
three separate and
significantly viewed tweet situations
last week where people were coming for
me and i didn't see any of it until
somebody else told me but here's if
you've ever worried about me being
harassed on twitter at the risk of this
sounding extremely arrogant i don't care
at all
i also don't care
if a youtuber is making a video about me
or someone's talking [ __ ] about me on
stream i don't care
this happens all the time
people come to me all the time and go
this person's harassing you
or that person's audience comes and
harasses me and the only thing i will
ever do
is occasionally if the volume of it is
high enough that i'm like okay this
person clearly has like some sort of
obsession and is going for this
repeatedly is just look up their
username and block them on twitter the
only reason i do that is because if it
escalates into real world harassment
then i have a case for saying i tried to
prevent this i did block them from
harassing me somewhere but they worked
around it that's it i'll never look at
the videos i'll never read the tweets
none of it um and again at the risk of
sounding arrogant the truth is my life
is so fulfilling
like i have a job that i really like my
friends are great i'm in a good position
financially i'm mentally and physically
healthy i love my family
i have no shortage of things to do there
is just no part of me
that has any interest in
looking up or caring about
what i view as children saying about
anything i do like i just
don't care at all like
like there isn't even a part of me
that's curious enough to look it up
there are like i think three male
youtubers who i guess either stream
about me or make videos about me
frequently enough that i i know their
names because their audiences come and
harass me all the time
not once have i ever looked at any of
their content again if it happens super
frequently i'll just go block them on
twitter just so that i have a case for
again if it escalates into stalking or
anything that's a thing that helps with
the police um
but
that's it i don't i just don't care like
i don't know how else to explain it
other than like it just couldn't matter
to me less there's my life's just super
fulfilling i always have a million
things i can do like
i don't know to me it seems very simple
but the fact that so many people contact
me all the time and are like there's
people harassing you i hope you're okay
has to put something into perspective or
it makes me feel like my perspective is
strange like that it's that it it's odd
to feel this way or to just not care but
like i'd literally look at anyone who
would again harass it doesn't really
feel like harassment if i don't even see
any of it um would be harassing me on
twitter for putting xbox gamepass in a
title while i work at a playstation
studio
as an actual child like even if it's a
grown man
if you come and tell me that that's
happening my head goes well that's an
infant why would i care i would never
listen to that person on the street why
would i go and like actively look at it
on the internet i just
i don't care at all
i never will care the only time it
matters is it feels like it's obsessive
and thus has risk of escalating to
real-world violence or whatever which
has happened before and i sometimes feel
like maybe that's like part of it like
part of this conversation is like i
don't care about
like
again random idiots on twitter talking
about me
because some of the harassment that i
receive is like actually serious and so
the scale of it is just way off like
some of it is like i know the local
police some of it actually matters yeah
so this like the people like talking
about console [ __ ] on twitter like i
just don't
care at all i i could not be less
interested in whoever these people are
again the same happens for these youtube
dudes who make videos about me who i
don't know like sometimes someone will
come to me and be like hey this guy made
this video about you this guy said it's
awful [ __ ] about you i said this about
you and i'm always just like why watch
if it's bothering you enough to report
it to me just stop watching his content
like i'm never gonna go watch it why on
earth would i waste my time with that i
don't know i feel like i have a very
healthy approach to it i hope it makes
sense again it just feels like an
unusual approach because people are
always so concerned and i'm just like i
didn't even [ __ ] know that was
happening um for context the reason i
never know is that my mentions are
filtered on twitter so i only ever see
ads from people i'm following if you're
if i'm not following you i will never
see anything you tweet at me um and
that's because like that's the way i
like to use that app i don't use it very
much there's also just like it's just so
stupid like it's just any of the console
war stuff is just so ridiculous that
entertaining it at all is like you're
just losing brain cells like i
my entire career have liked xbox
playstation and nintendo the whole time
um i've covered all three from from day
one i have always liked all three i was
on a playstation podcast for longer than
i was on an xbox podcast and uh yeah i
do the same thing for all the content
like anything that's about playstation
has a playstation logo it says
playstation anything's about xbox it
says xbox if it's on game pause it says
xbox game pass but also one thing to
note xbox will never sponsor me to do
anything um
and a lot of people probably don't know
this especially because it's like
unusual because it's sort of different
to what you would expect from xbox uh as
soon as i started working at playstation
xbox cut me off completely so like i was
removed from their mailing list i no
longer get codes uh no longer get
invited to events they used to like send
me stuff none of that anymore at all
obviously they went well within their
rights to do that i get it but it is
unusual um because like when i worked at
xbox playstation didn't do that to me
nor did nintendo nintendo still sends me
stuff now nintendo still sends codes now
so clearly they're not treating me that
way but xbox like the minute that i
started working playstation playstation
just i was just dead to them
uh which again they're well within their
rights to do doesn't matter but
playstation did not do that when i
worked at xbox so it's kind of like an
interesting one and then i can assure
you i think they would prefer i
literally didn't exist obviously that
doesn't color the way that i feel about
xbox properties i still played and
really enjoyed tuning uh i still really
like game pass there's a lot of i still
really care about halo even if i didn't
like the tv show um it's not going to
color how i feel about anything at all
but promise you xbox won't even give me
codes they are definitely not going to
pay me to do anything
i assure you
not happening it's manscaped time
manscaped is awesome because they are
doing a very good job of catering to the
big three otozones your butt your balls
and your body i appreciate the service
that they are doing to the general
public making people smell good and the
performance package has all of these
things covered starting with the
lawnmower 4.0 this is a waterproof
cordless trimmer it has replaceable
ceramic blades with skin safe technology
and a built-in led light so you can trim
with confidence it also has a wireless
charging dock and a travel safe lock so
nothing to worry about just good hygiene
we also have not a joke ball deodorant
this stuff is anti-chafing with active
ph control and it smells really good
is a quick absorbing clear drying
all-day moisturizer gives you all-day
protection from bad odors then if you
need a little bit more of a refresh
maybe you've been doing some exercise
hitting the club i don't know what you
do this is the bowl toner a nice mid-day
refresher that has aloe vera properties
and uh anti-inflammatory as well the
performance package 4.0 bundle also now
includes their new weed whacker nose and
ear hair trimmer it is a game changer
that'll keep you feeling fresh without
painful alternatives like plucking or
waxing plus when you opt in for the full
performance package 4.0 kit you get the
biggest bang for your buck you can
enroll in their peak hygiene plan and
get ongoing replenishments of your
favorite products delivered straight to
your door for a limited time you can
also get not one but two free gifts the
shed travel bag and the manscaped
anti-shaping boxer briefs so go to
manscape.com today and get 20 off plus
free international shipping plus two
free gifts what do you use promo code
alana 20 at checkout ffxman210 said can
you discuss what getting a green card
means and maybe the process for other
people trying to do the same voice
wonder what a green card does for you in
the day-to-day long-term yes so oh man
it's such a relief i
have been approved for a green card i do
not yet have my green card um a green
card means i'm a resident if you've
heard me speak at length about green
card visa stuff up until this point i
have worked in the us but not lived in
the u.s like every time that i fly into
the u.s and it asks uh what my home
address is i have to put my parents
address in australia that i've actually
never lived at because they do not
consider me a u.s resident a visa means
you just work in this country you don't
live here um despite the fact that i've
been here for like seven years now which
is obviously very strange and the
biggest headache with being here on a
visa and there are different visa
categories mine is an 01 visa which
legally classifies me as an alien of
extraordinary ability uh the application
process like my paperwork's like that
big um they often favor people who've
been to university for the thing that
they are doing professionally which
obviously applies to me you have to have
like a huge body of work and you have to
have like received accolades and
generally awards and a whole bunch of
other [ __ ] like that um to be considered
to get the one visa and then what is
effectively the green card from that is
an o1 green card um you have to be
considered in the top percentile of
people who have like made it in an
industry and for mine that was filed
under gaming which i take is a huge
compliment thank you
us government i really appreciate that
it's really hard to get it takes a lot
of a lot of effort um
difference between a visa and a green
card again is the green card means your
resident the green card means i can
legally make money right now i am only
allowed to earn money through the person
who owns my visa they pay me i cannot
make money on twitch i can't make money
on youtube i can't make money on patreon
i'm not allowed to make any income
in the us at all
outside of my
business manager so that's the way it's
all done right now is for
everything that i have that makes any
money at all uh it goes to my business
manager who then takes five percent cut
i think and then sends it to me um but
it all has to go to
the visa holder you're not allowed to
earn any independent money at all so
anytime anybody wants to work with me on
anything that would make any kind of
money it has to go through business
manager i cannot take any income
whatsoever i can't send an invoice none
of that [ __ ] um that's not allowed all
through one person um the biggest
headache of the visa which is how i
ended up in nicaragua is an one visa
after your first three years which it's
almost been you have to renew every year
and that basically means that every 12
months you have to file for a new visa
um which if it has any delay could cause
a period of time where you legally
aren't allowed to work at all like no
income whatsoever or every year
basically you're up for a new chance to
get declined it's still something that
hangs over your head really badly when
you live on a visa that you're just like
always worried about you can just lose
my whole life and just have to leave
just lose my job like that just get
fired because the government decides
just arbitrarily not this year my friend
green card on the other hand lasts i
believe 10 years um i've been here for
seven having 10 where i can earn money
legally live in the country which means
i can actually like go and get a
california id and i'd be applicable for
all of that kind of stuff i get tsa
pre-check i can get a gun like i can
start
actually living in the u.s where right
now they still consider me to be an
australian resident and i don't have to
worry about the renewal process yeah
green card basically means you legally
get to work in the country the green
card process is different depending on
what category you apply for mine again
being an 01 or one adjacent is
effectively a talent green card so it is
for yeah people who have achieved uh
a specific amount of stuff which is why
awards were helpful that was why i asked
people to vote for me for youtuber of
the year which thank you so much for
doing that because i have no doubt that
it contributed i imagine the forbes 30
under 30 thing really helped as well
like being recognized for the thing that
you do means you're more likely to get
approved for the green card otherwise
it's just a hell of a lot of paperwork
and some very good lawyers putting it
all together so that you don't have to
you have to go get a bunch of pictures
taken and sign a bunch of [ __ ] and
yeah my lawyers really did the bulk of
it that they were awesome they do all
the sourcing where like it helps a lot
for a green card if you've been
interviewed a bunch and obviously i do
interviews all the time or you've been
on like different podcasts or whatever
else so yeah the the process would be
very very different for most people but
the o1 process is mostly just about um
putting a lot of paperwork together
sending it off spending a [ __ ] ton of
money to send it off and the worst part
of that is if they decline it you don't
get any of the application money back my
next thing that i have to do for it is
next month i have to get biometrics done
i don't really know what that is i just
know that i have an appointment at like
a u.s government center where they do my
biometrics i didn't get to choose when
the appointment was they just said hey
you hear this now biometrics and if i
delay it it would delay the green card
and then i think i have an interview i
don't actually know what happens from
here all i know is right now i'm not
allowed to travel internationally i can
only fly domestically i'm not allowed to
leave the us until the green card is
done and i imagine at some point when
this process is over i think it takes
like six months i'll have to send off my
passport and they'll physically put a
card inside of the passport but i
honestly don't know i'm so relieved
though i was so worried i was gonna get
rejected it's such a lifesaver living in
this country on a visa is so stressful
because it can just be taken away from
you at any point and the period of time
you have to file which i've done
four times in total now three times it's
just a nightmare it's so much work that
it's like having an extra job that you
have to pay ten thousand dollars for or
whatever it is i have not actually paid
it myself my employees have always paid
it but oh it's such a relief i'm so glad
to have it
thank god wicked raven said hey where
did you get that stand for your god of
war statues this stand right here
there's a video about it up on the
channel it's from a company called
pedestal source
it's so cool it's actually not plugged
in right now because i had contractors
in
fixing some kind of water damage i don't
know the building paid for it it's not
my responsibility but it it is beautiful
i love it so much it's so cool i'm
really happy with how the office is like
slowly coming together ryan said what
was your experience like going from a
studio apartment to a larger
multi-bedroom space how are you
utilizing the biggest space is just the
biggest place you've lived since coming
to the states um yeah so i actually
looked it up the other day my apartment
in san francisco was 300 square foot it
wasn't even big enough because the
kitchen was so big actually it wasn't
even big enough for me to have a tv um
so i did have a tv i think i probably
still have the video on my channel here
but i had it in the wardrobe because
there was nowhere else for me to put it
so i would like have to slide the
wardrobe door open to find the tv um
which is like god it was brutal and then
the one in la was 320 square foot so a
little bit bigger it was enough that i
had a tv thankfully that was not in a
wardrobe but
in both of those apartments all of my
clothes were in the kitchen cupboards
because there wasn't enough room
otherwise this is the biggest place that
i've lived since moving here definitely
yes and i am just so much happier on
average the the thing isn't
the space helps but the space isn't
actually the biggest thing the thing
that makes me the happiest about being
here is that i have windows everywhere
that i've lived beforehand the other two
apartments i guess um and i did live in
a house before that so even that house
the only window just looked at concrete
wall or another building i couldn't see
anything outside of the window it was
just another building so right now it's
not like i'm not also just looking at a
concrete wall in another building but
it's a lot more space like i can see the
sky
and
that has like done something so
different to my brain it's so i think i
might have mentioned that in a video
before it's so nice to be able to see
the sky one thing i'm also really liking
is this is obviously the first place
that i've lived that i've been allowed
to have a dog so i've fostered two dogs
so far i should find out about my next
one probably late this week or the week
after about my next foster uh they're
waiting to find out if he's approved to
live in a house that has stairs because
he has a neurological issue i keep
taking in dogs that have medical issues
um just because i feel like they need
the extra help and i'm happy to help um
and yeah new more spaces obviously super
helpful oh sorry the other thing i was
going to mention is i'm allowed to have
plants i wasn't allowed to have plants
in either of the other two and as an
asthmatic it's really nice to have
plants because they purify the air in
like such a different way than even air
purifiers do so it's so good for me to
have um because they're just nice in
general so the space is obviously very
nice yes i feel like a real human and
not like a robot who just wakes up works
wakes up works like i i spend more time
in rooms that are not my office because
previously my whole room was my office
and it's really really really nice yeah
i'm also having fun decorating and yeah
it's the biggest place i've lived since
coming to the states by a lot and um
very very very very very nice i'm so
excited to have my family come visit
because there's space for them and
beforehand if my parents came to stay
obviously they would just have to sleep
on a blowout mattress on the floor next
to me in the studio apartment which is
not ideal and now i feel like i have a
space where i can have guests and i'm
like right now like planning to buy
towels and like i don't know just like
have a place where i can have them visit
that i'm just very excited about it's
really nice being a family i just wanted
to say there are a lot of comments in
here um i said in the last q a it was
like i may increase sponsorships you may
see more sponsorships on the channel uh
because i have an oil family member and
i am trying to help my family
financially right now um and
if you missed that that's a thing there
may be more sponsorships i may do more
of that stuff so that i can make sure
that i can afford to help them um trying
really hard to do that uh but there are
a lot of people in the comments here who
were
basically saying bring it on and and
saying some really nice stuff um about
the situation which is really tough so i
just wanted to say thank you i really
appreciate that it's very kind of you
and i think i will leave it
there everybody thank you so much for
watching thank you to manchester
sponsoring the channel they are a very
fun one to do i like working with them
they're like not only very easy to work
with and promote good hygiene which is
the thing i'm a very big fan of
but also it just feels very funny so
huge thank you to manscaped uh otherwise
i will see you guys next time leave
questions for the next one below
[Music]